oh just you just got to be ballsy but
you and and in following and and doing
some research that your career was
always about being ballsy whether it was
in school and putting together comedy
nights or uh phoning and and chasing
people that you were fans of and
interviewing them or you were do without
working for anybody just on your own you
are ballsy I interviewed you yeah did
you yes
as a kid as a kid when I was 16 I
interviewed you over the phone
I somehow got you to talk to me in
probably 1980
four
and uh and I'm sure I I have the tape
somewhere oh really maybe I'll send it
please send it to me I'm gonna put it
into this you could slice it but the
worst part is I have this Long Island
accent so I'm like a kid my voice hasn't
really broken yet so I'm like so how
what's the life doing and
we don't have to have it that way he
just recreated that moment right now I
want to hear that that's amazing
hello
to you uh about a week ago about an
interview oh yeah right right I just got
your message I just got back in town I
saw you on the telephone
pretty good Jay Lewis complimenting it
yeah
um do you think you could have any time
before I'm leaving on Saturday morning
oh sure let's do it uh
tomorrow morning tomorrow morning sure
uh let me get up let's see then later
tonight better for you no I'm going over
to the ice house to interview the
unknown comic Murray Langston yeah
um tomorrow morning okay where do you
want to do it
how long is this going to take about a
half hour
I mean if you want to cut the shirt I
can okay
so how about giving me a shout about 11
30.
okay
11 30. okay all right so you want to do
this over the phone or in person uh
you know something over the phone might
be better because I can call you from
wherever I am or you call me here and
the only reason I say over the phone is
because even if I'm not home I'll we'll
do it yeah you know that way I can
I only get a couple days in between
I only got tomorrow off it's my only day
and I have to go do some [__] in the
morning yeah so
um should I give you a call you're going
to call me at 11 30 tomorrow okay sure
that'll be great see you later bye-bye
[Music]